there's this one exercise you had
recently on your channel maybe you've
referenced it before but i saw it in one
of your most recent videos
about the alphabet and visualizing it on
a grid
yeah are you able to see all 26 letters
at once
in your mind's eye no but that's a good
question
so when we think about can you see 26
letters at once
what do we mean by seeing 26 letters at
once right
so if i if i think you mean what i think
you mean then the answer is no
but at the same time there is an image
of the alphabet
and i can see that yeah see mike was
doing it i don't think i even
did the entire exercise but what i
gathered from it
i can imagine that i could vaguely see
the entire alphabet
and that i can trick myself into
thinking i'm seeing the alphabet because
my eyes just like my eyes right now are
secating around and i get an image of
the hole but i'm actually only seeing a
part at any point
i imagine that let's say i'm looking at
well what's around g
then i go around g and i see the plus or
minus around g maybe plus or minus two
plus or minus three
around g when i say plus or minus i mean
the letters and then i secade down to z
and then i sub it up to
q and so on and i think that i'm seeing
all 26 letters but i'm not
so you're saying that the point of the
exercise isn't
to visualize all 26 at once nor is it
well
that's not the point of the exercise the
point of the exercise
is to help people begin to understand
what the memory tradition is
and how it's how and why
it working with what used to be called
the gamatria is useful i mean it's still
called the camitria
but a lot of memory techniques involve
understanding that language is built
from alphabet and alphabet
builds language and what we're doing
when we use memory techniques
is we're perceiving a sort of
fundamental oneness or sameness in
information
that is differentiated by symbols and
there's multiple levels of mental
imagery so when i just said i can see
the alphabet as a singular thing i
actually don't even mean that i can see
it
because seeing is the thing that eyes do
right um
but the a notion that eyes
is an image that appears in my mind
right so
even the idea that eyes are a thing that
sees
is a mental image that has multiple
properties
right that is appearing as an image
inside of my own image
of my own consciousness i don't
understand what i could do
i don't even know if i understand it
either